when you start doing stand-up where do
you go to start did you start in a
bowling alley or something
yeah yeah where do you go to start doing
stand-ups so in staten island there is
no
where to really you know do stand up
there's no big comedy scene no there's
an island not a really hot scene
um it's just a bunch of restaurants
right um and when you first go to the
bowling alley
yeah to do stand-up yeah it's a comedy
club in a bowling alley
attached to a wendy's and a la fitness
well in a way that's got to be the
hardest place on the [ __ ] planet
to make anybody laugh dude staten island
number one worst place for comedy
okay nothing there is funny so describe
this to me do you have something written
down on a piece of paper
i had like i used to write word for word
what i was gonna say like i would have
like four or five pages back to back and
just like
and would you memorize them i would to
the best of my ability at the time yeah
because i never did it before so i would
just you know practice in the mirror or
like
yeah that's what i bug my one friend
that i had and be like is this funny
because that's what i find [ __ ]
amazing about stand-ups i mean i've
interviewed jerry seinfeld all these
guys and you know jerry writes
everything down too when he writes yeah
he's a perfectionist he's a
perfectionist about
every single word and every you know and
then you talk to tracy morgan and he
kind of just wings it
he's just like buttholes right yeah it's
hilarious yeah yeah he's one of those
dudes that could like read the phone
book and like
he's just funny he's this funny guy so
when you go to the bowling alley
and i would think this is the hardest
place to make people laugh
they don't know you you don't bring your
friends because you had none
and you go up there and how many people
are there even but
20 30 like it's a bringer show which is
like what you do is like to get on stage
you got to bring like four people
whatever so i brought these two kids
that like were friends with me
they're on my basketball team and they
were friends with me when the team
wasn't around
right like so they wouldn't be
embarrassed being seen with you
yeah holy [ __ ] you were more you sound a
little more popular than me
no they were just maybe maybe a little
bit i had like i feel like these two
they liked me a lot but like if we were
in a group of people like they were like
hey man like we can't be seen with this
like later yeah because we'll talk about
it later we're having our own problems
we don't need to be linked with you oh
my god that's like the worst
nightmare in the world so embarrassing
oh such a loser
so did you kill that night were you
funny
it went okay right um when you first
start doing stand up and you do okay
okay feels like oh wow
where where are they at when i'm ready
sign me up hollywood
yeah so like i was kind of on my high
horse right
i felt really good about myself and then
do you go do it a hundred more times and
it's not the same experience
the second time went just as good and
then i bombed for like a month straight
why do you think you bombed all of a
sudden did you get tight
no i think it's just like uh some
audiences were like oh that's like a
young kid like good for him
you know and then i think you know some
crowds are like [ __ ] this kid i paid
ten dollars what's your relationship
like with nick cannon because
he seems to me to be a [ __ ] it's some
kind of mentor of yours right like he
said
what did he see you early on in doing
stand-up and said this kid's got
something
yeah he used to do a radio show here
right and one of his co-hosts
uh found me at the looney bin doing
stand-up and then recommended that's the
bowling alley play yeah the bowling
alley
the looney bin it actually worked out
right so so you meet
nick because it seems to me as one of
the youngest guys that ever got
signed to saturday night live it was a
quick thing you meet nick
he puts you on tv with that you get a
little role in a movie
yeah with uh with bill hader yeah and
hater says
to lauren you think yeah i met this kid
he's funny you should put him on
saturday night live
that's what i was told that's amazing
yeah like there was no big struggle
no i i mean yeah i mean like i did a lot
of stuff but like a kind of
right place right time always i had a
lot of help
like i was on set for that movie for
like two hours and then i
i maybe said five words to bill and then
i got a call and he was like bill loved
you i was like i don't even know if i i
didn't say a word to him he was just so
nice
this is the amy schumer movie trainwreck
yeah and you had a small part
yeah amy just you know was nice enough
to give me a little part and
i met them and then yeah amy knew you're
from stand up mm-hmm
and she said you want to be in my movie
yeah it was so nice though my
god that's [ __ ] crazy weird well you
like um
i'm not even ready for that i was like
dude that's a bad idea i was like i've
ever recommended anybody i was like i
don't think i should be your first one
i was like definitely you could
recommend someone else i was like dude
that's a bad idea you're an amazing guy
like you you're
very self-conscious for somebody in show
business like you're just like you know
what don't don't recommend me for
anything no i know this is all [ __ ]
you don't even believe it yeah this is
all wrestling well i mean what did you
say to bill that was so funny did you
ever ask him did you ever say bill what
did you see in me that was so great no
we just like improved
for like you know 15 minutes and then i
was just like hey man like really nice
to meet you or whatever and he was very
nice and we laughed a little bit
i went i left that being like okay that
guy doesn't hate me and acting wasn't
your thing
it wasn't like you said to yourself i
want to be on saturday night live i want
to be a sketch comedian i've never done
improv i don't even know how to do that
[ __ ]
like i i here's what i saw i was like i
really love stand up i just want to do
stand-up because it's the only place
where i could
have full control and say whatever i
want right and if anything else happens
it's just a bonus and i still feel that
way yes stand-up's really the only thing
i care about you know so it's whatever i
could do to like do that the most
you